بغداد طبعا انا اظهر اليوم من عند تمثال
شهريار وشهرزات عن عن قصدير لانه هذا
التمثال الذي هو خلفي تنساش شهرزاد هو اول
تمثال اعطى درس
للعالم كله بان المراه القادره على ترويض
رجل
سفاح النساء مثل شهريار هي قادره على فعل
اي شيء في المستقبل نعم وكل عام وانتم
بالف خير يا سهام ونادين
زميلاتي مراسلات كذلك يسعدلي صباحك يا
زينب وصباح كل مراسلات صباح العربيه ونحن
مستمرون مع مراسلات صباح العربيه نذهب
معكم الى مصر ففي كل بلد هناك عينات
ونماذج كثيره من النساء اللواتي تركن بصمه
في هذه الدنيا ويتركن وايضا هم قدوه لجيل
المستقبل وابناء اليوم ندى حجازي ستعرفنا
ربما على اول سائقه مترو في مصر عندما
كانت هذه المهنه حكرا على الرجال المراه
تريد والمراه تستطيع وان تستطيع ان تحلم
اليك يا ندى
صباح الخير نادين صباح الخير سهام في
الحقيقه السيدات المصريات حققوا انجازات
كتير خلال الفتره اللي فاتت فاحنا عندنا
الاول مره المراه المصريه بتجلس على منصه
المحكمه بمجلس الدوله واول مره المراه
المصريه تمثل النيابه العامه امام محكمه
الجنايات وكمان لاول مره المترو بقياده
نسائيه زي ما حكيتوا عشان كده انا اخترت
النهارده محطه المترو تكون خلفيتي في البث
ده وانا دايما باسعد باقتحام النساء
لمجالات كانت حكر على الرجال فكل عام
والمراه المصريه والعربيه والعالميه تحقق
احلامها بحريه دون قيود من المراه المصريه
للمراه الاردنيه هذه المره مع سها جميل
يسعد صباحك يسوع كل عام وانت بالف خير
اهلا بك
صباح الخير بدايه ما اجمل صباح العربيه
عندما تقدمه سيدتين جميلتين وهذا ما ينطبق
على كل ما تقدمه المراه
كل عام وجميع النساء بالف خير قصتي عن
الحاضره الغائبه السيده اسماء خضر التي
تستحق اليوم ذكرى في هذا يوم المراه
العالمي رحلت في عام 2021 وهي ناشطه
حقوقيه اضافه الى انها سياسيه اردنيه شغلت
الكثير من المناصب منها كانت وزيره
للاعلام اضافه الى انها كانت عضو في مجلس
الاعيان وكانت وزيره للثقافه مرتين
متتاليتين لكنها ايضا ناشطه حقوقيه محاميه
في معهد تضامن النسائي الاردني نادت بحقوق
المراه وما زال هذا المعهد يعمل كانت ضد
زواج الفتيات في عمر مبكر كانت ضد اعفاء
الرجل المختصب في حاله تزوجه من الضحيه
بان يعفى من العقاب كانت تنادي بالتج
ابناء الاردنيات وكانت تحمل كثير من
السيدات من خلال دعوه ما يعرف بجرائم
الشرف اسمى خضر استمرت في هذا العمل
لسنوات في معهد تضامن كانت تعمل على تمكين
المراه اقتصاديا واجتماعيا كانت تبحث عن
فرص للحياه للمراه وما زال هذا المعهد
يعمل بنفس الراحله اسمى خضر وكانت هناك
العديد من اللقاءات لهذه السيده وكانت
يعني تحمي العديد من السيدات بدعوى يعني
الهروب من جرائم الشرف وقد شهدت الكثير من
قصص النجاح لسيدات في الارياف وفي الباديه
وحتى في مجتمعاتنا الحضريه والمدنيه لانها
كانت دائما تنادي بالمساواه التي ما زالت
نساء العالم ايضا تنادي بها حتى هذه
اللحظه على كل حال سهاله سعيده جدا بهذا
اللايف بالسداسي الذي يجمعنا كنساء على
الهواء مباشره في يوم المراه العالمي
سباعي عم بيقولوا لي بس كمان خلينا نروح
لواشن ولا هند ابراهيم هند باليوم المراه
العالمي اول شغله تسمحي لي اني ارحب فيك
وهاي لاول مره هند معانا مباشره في صباح
العربيه وجها لوجه بنتقابل معاك اهلا
وسهلا فيك في فريق صباح العربيه هند
سمعتوا على تقارير هند طوال الفتره
الماضيه هذا اولا وثانيا هند اليوم المراه
العالمي بدا من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ماذا تقولين في هذا اليوم
اولا صباح الخير سهام ونادين وكل عام
وانتم وجميع مشاهداتنا ونساء العالم بالف
خير
وبهذه المناسبه ساتحدث لكم عن المراه
الاكثر اثاره في عالم التكنولوجيا ميرا
موراتي وميرا تبلغ من العمر 35 عاما فقط
لكنها كبيره المسؤولين التكنولوجيين في
شركه اوبن اي اي الشركه المسؤوله عن تطوير
الروبات ذكاء الاصطناعي
الذي اكتسح العالم مؤخرا وكنا قد غطينا
هذا الموضوع في السابق
ميراك تخرجت عام 2012
بكالوريوس بالهندسه ومنذ ذلك الحين والى
الان وهي تقود فرق في اهم الشركات
التكنولوجيه العالميه منها شركه تسلا حيث
عملت لمده ثلاث سنوات تحديدا لتطوير طراز
من هذه السياره الكهربائيه ثم انتقلت
للعمل مع شركه ليب موشن وكان املها ان
تلغي الكيبورد من الكمبيوتر او
اللوح لوحه المفاتيح املا بان تجعل
الكمبيوتر علاقته بالناس وكانت قد تحدثت
عنها قالت انها تعمل الناس مع الكمبيوتر
كانهم يلعبون كره القدم واخيرا في عام
انضمت الى شركه اوبن اي اي حينها كانت
الشركه
30075 موظف فقط وهي كانت شركه ناشئه لكن
بعمل ميرا موراتي تحولت هذه الشركه الان
الى شركه تقدر ارادتها ب 30 مليار دولار
عالميا وطبعا وهناك اكثر من 100 مليون
مستخدم
شهريا وهي ايضا
تعمل على
وهو ايضا ذكاء لكن يمكن ان يقوم باعمال
فنيه من الممكن ان ينشا لوحات وتماثيل
والى اخره من التصميمات
ميرا ايضا انتقلت كمان لانه لسه الساعتين
طوال للاحتفال بيوم المراه العالمي
والمراه امام الذكاء الاصطناعي لديها ذكاء
اجتماعي فانا اشكركم جزيل الشكر من واشنطن
هند ابراهيم اشكر ايضا ندى حجازي من
القاهره واشكر ايضا زينب المشاط من بغداد
وسها جميل من عمان شكرا لكلنا